sans délai les appareils tout de suite
on s'en doute est arrivé philippe
candeloro
bienvenue à bord et des plans d euros
bonsoir tout ça on se connaît pas on
sait jamais vu je connaissais mon ami
dont on se connaît oui et alors ça s'est
bien passé la première fois très bien on
va vous faire une hyper view alors une
hyper view vous allez voir la lumière va
baisser dès que je vais poser la
première question et recours peut vous
poser des questions
laurent peut vous poser des questions et
catherine que vous posez des questions
et moi je vais pas me marque avait
toutefois si freddy qui est un homme
politique italien tels s'arrange comment
alors ils connaissaient entre siffredi
non il a joué dans d'argent il a joué
dans doctor rocco et mister chrono
mélange blanc connaît le grand pardon
oui ou non quoi aussi mr
gbagbo en carrière
oh que oui jacques lacan vous me parlez
de blanche neige et les sept nains
philippe candeloro donc après votre
médaille de bronze à nagano vous avez
décidé de passer pro c'est ça ça y est
c'est fait depuis un an voilà on est une
femme à tort mais dites-moi médaille de
bronze et à l'international vous n'avez
jamais été premiers n'ont jamais en fait
jamais eu de titre suprême donc c'est ce
qui est en berne un peu de monde les
femmes ouais en fait je suis autant
voire plus médiatique certains champions
du monde champions olympiques donc ça
paraît bizarre mais bon c'est comme ça
j'y suis enfin moi je suis pour rien
quoi ça vous fait une tournée qui
s'appelle le camp del euros à tour un
putois et donc professionnel surya
bonaly ça
surya et ai été avec moi donc voilà on a
fait une première partie de la tournée
sur civile au mois de mars
donc comme c'est ma première tournée
j'organisais six mois le producteur
c'est moi qui fais tout bon c'est un peu
c'est un peu lourd
enfin je viens il ya beaucoup de choses
où il faut faire attention donc c'est
vrai que financièrement j'ai pris encore
un petit peu mal mais mon chaque
production en fait en diminuer le
déficit parce que vous aviez beaucoup de
problèmes d'argent avec la fédé à
l'époque il voulait jamais vous donner
ce qui vous devez bien servi là pour
sept produits les bus doivent toujours
de l'argent la fédération de lui et ça
toujours pas été réglée la faire mais
c'est dingue je voulais qu'on lance un
appel dans les avocats sans temps de
s'en occuper
ils lancent des appels d'accord alors qu
a surtout rendu populaire quand léo
c'est d'abord sa voix et sa tchatche
parce que d'abord il pas on lui pose la
question il répond m et surtout il a
cette gouaille de titi parisien qui fait
que tout de suite les imitateurs se sont
emparés de lui et alors même quand il
parlait pas on entendait on entendait la
radio guignols et ça c'est ça qui fait
parler mieux en plus un pardon pas les
mieux pas les meilleurs imitateurs y en
a certains qu'est ce qu'il convient là
ici plus qu ministre il s'appelle là il
est en face de moi aujourd'hui mais je
me rappel puissant mais moi je suis pas
l'imitateur vraiment pas du tout pas mal
ma gueule c'est vrai que je t ai ramassé
beaucoup les guignols qui m'ont fait
aussi un bon coup de pub c'est comme ça
vous avez d un pc ou les mois je me suis
jamais je me suis jamais fâché en fête
avec eux et c'est ça qui est formidable
voilà un mec quelques est resté sympa
parce que vous pouvez dire les pires
conneries sur lui et ça me faisait
marrer c'est pas que ça m'arrivait de
rigoler des propres connaît où il se
foutait de ma gueule moi j'allume la
télé pour regarder les guignols ou une
émission de divertissement c'est pour
rire c'est pas pour lui avoir dit tiens
il a raté un triple saut ses parents eux
l'ont réussi ça c'était pas ça patinage
et qu'est ce que j'ai pu dire les
américains on nous envoie les cochons
qui parlent les anglais ont la vache
folle union lalanne qui patine ici mais
n'a jamais foutu son plein la gueule
cette fête pour ce soir
avec les points je vais régler ça je
vais est invité sur la glace et puis tu
verras ça patine j'ai tout mon dieu je
ne quittais pas la rambarde
c'était terrible voilà finalement
c'était pas moi alors en france
j'ai quand même une réputation tu peux
je pas si je me trompe vous connaissez
bien philippe mais un peu grande gueule
médiatiques ou à vous c'est vrai vous
parlez de vous la troisième personne ça
vous arrive ça
non enfin je parle là comme je vous
parle aujourd'hui on voit aussi jamais
quand des comme alain delon jénine
candeloro a soif voix il ya trois
semaines j'ai fais une confiance de
presse donc pour la tournée du camp dès
le retour est vrai que j'ai un peu
employé la troisième personne est en
fait bon c'était un peu une erreur quoi
bon vous l'aurez parce que de langeac
pas je regrette pas mais bon c'est vrai
que vaut mieux parler de soi brogniart
jeu et puis voilà bah ouais on parle
plus moi ce qui me fait rire
en tout cas chez candeloro et c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il a revolution nous
évidemment c'était du pain béni pour les
humoristes mais ce qui a révolutionné le
patinage c'est quand même qu'ils
venaient déguisé il ya eu là bas on
allait venir j'imagine c'est les
costumes hr moi je veux dire j'ai noté
je me souviens d'artagnan d'artagnan
lucky luke
lucky luke conan conan le barbare le
parrain me paraissent ka-zar oh non non
non pas ça en fait
irina polonais le choix entre d'artagnan
et d'artagnan euros et fanfan la tulipe
en fait s'ils avaient un choix mais
c'est cape et d'épée qui m'intéressent
vu qu'elle panoplie pour noël dernier
là j'ai eu batman george de la jungle
george de la jungle c'est ce que j'ai
fait sur ma tournée
alors je faisais une impro tous les
soirs en fait tu veux apporter le
spectacle philippe candeloro on dit
souvent que vous faites du cinéma du ce
cinéma-là en tous les cas pour cacher
vos faiblesses techniques c'est vrai pas
la faiblesse technique plus la faiblesse
artistique parce qu'en fait quand
j'étais jeune j'aimais pas du tout
l'artistique et pour faire un mec qui
fait du patinage artistique c'est un peu
gênant
oui donc c'est pour moi lever un bras ça
faisait ça faisait gonzesses et puis je
me suis avec mon copain hockeyeurs qui
vous disaient à colombes à vous êtes sur
la bord et le co peut accueillir lui
disais que ça score de paix d'alger
vient plutôt faire du hockey tu verras
finalement après on apprend que les
hockeyeurs finalement dans le vestiaire
il sans manches